you came back for more that's awesome so
let's talk about what products can do
for us how they give us value that we're
willing to pay for products can do one
or a combination of three things they
can do things cheaper than competitors
they can outperform competitors or they
can make you feel differently and
perhaps better than competitors so a car
can give us value because it's cheaper
than a competitor or it can be more
fuel-efficient or maybe it's just got a
cool logo that makes us feel proud to
drive it or all three branding which is
a set of associations that a consumer
has about a product is an example of
psychological value a brand is meant to
make a consumer feel a certain way it
doesn't change how fast the car drives
it changes how exciting the ride feels
people are willing to pay for products
that are branded because they value the
feelings that the specific brand gives
them some people feel that brands are
branding or wrong there was even a book
called quote no logo to criticize the
ultra branded world in which we live but
if brands are wrong then feelings are
wrong and I don't think that anyone
would argue that there's something bad
about having feelings even about things
we consume let's talk about an example
of an unconventional brand you might not
have heard the name Calvin Cortazar
Brodus jr. but you probably are familiar
with Snoop Doggy Dogg
Snoop created his brand by capitalizing
on the fact that people were interested
in his music but he didn't limit himself
to music he used his music as a platform
to entice listeners to find out more
about himself Snoop Dogg made elements
of himself elements that have nothing to
do with music available for the public
to see so he created a TV game show he
appeared at football games he did a
cooking special with Martha Stewart he
even created a nature show called planet
Earth essentially he helped fans
generate associations and feelings about
him and not simply his rap and its
lyrics through marketing Snoop was able
to move from being just a voice in
people's minds to personality that they
care to discover he licensed his
likeness and used PR to generate press
and TV appearances in addition his
ubiquity included participation and
other musicians were
even more mainstream pop like Katy Perry
and Miley Cyrus the Pussycat Dolls
Mariah Carey and some hip-hop like
matome oh here's the thing about
psychological value that's so important
psychological value provides a form of
differentiation the consumers care about
and create reasons to buy something when
a product is otherwise the same
functionally think of a car all cars
have engines many of the same size and
power and many features are exactly the
same so what makes you buy a BMW / an
Audi or Mercedes when their performance
and price are very similar the big
differences are in the associations we
have with each brand those associations
are pure psychological value when BMW
calls itself the ultimate driving
machine it's appealing to one element in
our psychology that is different from
Audi x' which says never blend in kind
of like Snoop Dog